what is tragic to you what is our lhf
reinforcement learning with human
feedback what is that little magic
ingredient
to the dish that made it uh so much more
delicious
so we we trained these models uh on a
lot of Text data and in that process
they they learned the underlying
something about the underlying
representations of what's in here or in
there and they can do
amazing things but when you first play
with that base model that we call it
after you finish training it can do very
well on evals it can pass tests it can
do a lot of you know there's knowledge
in there but it's not very useful
uh or at least it's not easy to use
let's say and rlhf is how we take some
human feedback the simplest version of
this is show two outputs ask which one
is better than the other uh which one
the human Raiders prefer and then feed
that back into the model with
reinforcement learning and that process
works remarkably well within my opinion
remarkably little data to make the model
you're more useful so rlhf is how we
align the model to what humans want it
to do so there's a giant language model
that's trained in a giant data set to
create this kind of background wisdom
knowledge that's contained within the
internet
and then
somehow adding a little bit of human
guidance on top of it through this
process
makes it seem so much more awesome
maybe just because it's much easier to
use it's much easier to get what you
want you get it right more often the
first time and ease of use matters a lot
even if the base capability was there
before and like a feeling like it
understood the question you're asking or
like it feels like you're kind of on the
same page it's trying to help you it's
the feeling of alignment yes I mean that
could be a more technical term for it
and you're saying that not much data is
required for that not much human
supervision is required for that to be
fair we understand the science of this
part at a much
earlier stage than we do the science of
creating these large pre-trained models
in the first place but yes less data
much less data that's so interesting the
science of
human guidance
that's a very interesting science and
it's going to be a very important
science to understand
how to make it usable how to make it
wise how to make it ethical how to make
it aligned in terms of all the kinds of
stuff we think about
uh and it matters which of the humans
and what is the process of incorporating
that human feedback and what are you
asking the humans is it two things that
you're asking them to rank things what
aspects are you uh letting or asking the
humans to focus in on it's really
fascinating but um
how uh what is the data set it's trained
on can you kind of loosely speak to the
enormity of this data so pre-training
data set the pre-training data set I
apologize we spend a huge amount of
effort pulling that together from many
different sources
um there's like a lot of there are open
source databases of of information uh we
get stuff via Partnerships there's
things on the internet
um it's a lot of our work is building a
great data set
how much of it is the memes subreddit
not very much maybe it'd be more fun if
it were more
so some of it is Reddit some of his new
sources all like a huge number of
newspapers there's like the general web
there's a lot of content in the world
more than I think most people think yeah
there is uh like too much
like where like the task is not to find
stuff but the filter out yeah right yeah
was is there a magic to that because
that seems there seems to be several
components to solve
the uh the design of the you could say
algorithms like their architecture the
neural networks maybe the size of the
neural network there's the selection of
the data
there's the the uh human supervised
aspect of it with you know uh RL with
human feedback yeah I think one thing
that is not that well understood about
creation of this final product like what
it takes to make gbt4 the version of it
we actually ship out that you get to use
inside of child GPT the number of pieces
that have to all come together and then
we have to figure out either new ideas
or just execute existing ideas really
well at every stage of this pipeline
um there's quite a lot that goes into it
so there's a lot of problem solving like
you've already said for gpt4 in in the
blog post and in general
there's already kind of a maturity
that's happening on some of these steps
like being able to predict before doing
the full training of well how the model
will behave isn't that so remarkable by
the way that there's like you know
there's like a lot of science that lets
you predict for these inputs here's
what's going to come out the other end
like here's the level of intelligence
you can expect is it close to a science
or is it still
uh because you said the word law in
science which are very ambitious terms
close to us close to right all right
let's be accurate yes I'll say it's way
more scientific than I ever would have
dared to imagine so you can really know
the uh The Peculiar characteristics of
the fully trans system from just a
little bit of training you know like any
new branch of science there's we're
gonna discover new things that don't fit
the data and have to come up with better
explanations and you know that is the
ongoing process of Discovery in science
but with what we know now even what we
had in that gpd4 blog post like I think
we should all just like be in awe of how
amazing it is that we can even predict
to this current level yeah you look at a
one-year-old baby and predict
how it's going to do on the SATs I don't
know
uh seemingly an equivalent one but
because here we can actually in detail
introspect various aspects of the system
you can predict